les crédits de la défense augmentent
c'est une réalité mais aussi
fondamentale qu'elle soit elle n'est pas
suffisante car les leçons du 24 février
sont encore attirés la guerre en Ukraine
constitue un tournant stratégique qui
coïncide en outre avec la fin de
l'opération barkhane ces deux événements
majeurs doivent nous conduire à une
réflexion d'ensemble que la récente
revue nationale stratégique n'a fait
qu'effleurer de notre point de vue elle
porte sur le modèle d'armée que nous
devons développer pour être en mesure de
relever le défi de la haute intensité
face à cette hypothèse qui se réimpose à
nous certains ont avancé l'idée que nos
armées ne pourraient couvrir qu'un front
très réduit sur une distance à peu près
équivalente de celle existantes entre
l'île et Dunkerque bien évidemment il
s'agit que d'un élément statistique mais
cela nécessite de prendre conscience de
nos difficultés d'épaisseur de nos
armées ce qui est bien connu a été et a
été souligné par nombre de d'orateurs
précédents
certes nos forces ont vocation à être
engagées en coalition quant à nous
intérêts vitaux ils sont
fondamentalement protégés par la
dissuasion mais nous commençons je pense
à mesurer tout juste l'ampleur de
l'effort qui est devant nous et cet
effort il devra être porté par la future
lprm bien sûr des enseignements doivent
être tirés de la guerre en Ukraine ou de
l'opération barkhane mais gardons à
l'esprit qu'on ne peut préparer la
guerre de demain en répondant aux
problématiques d'aujourd'hui avoir une
guerre de retard c'est toujours le
danger
ultime et le piège à éviter absolument
l'histoire est riche malheureusement en
enseignement à ce sujet c'est pourquoi
il est crucial de bien en percevoir les
leçons géostratégiques autant sans doute
que les enseignements militaires il faut
donc être à l'affût des signaux faibles
est-ce que nous le sommes suffisamment
c'est tout l'objet du processus qui
devait démarrer avec la revue nationale
stratégique des risques et des menaces
identifiés découlent les besoins et ses
besoins déterminent les moyens à mettre
en œuvre cet enchaînement logique doit
être le de la prochaine LPM pour
l'aborder dans de bonnes conditions nous
souhaitons monsieur le ministre être
pleinement informé c'est
particulièrement vrai des décisions qui
seront prises sur un chaînon qui est à
ce stade manquant celui de la définition
des besoins qui formera le satur de la
future programmation
en effet ces capitales notre effort de
défense devrait être compris pour être
accepté il devra être poursuivi dans un
temps long et supposera de lourds
efforts budgétaires il doit donc être
expliqué aux Français et pour réfléchir
et pour réussir il devra reposer sur
l'implication de chacun car s'il n'y
avait qu'une seule chose à retenir de la
guerre Ukraine ce serait peut-être que
la force d'une nation tient d'abord à
son moral à l'engagement et à la
cohésion de sa population